was one of the coolest experience I've
ever had yeah it brought back a lot of
memories like travel ball days yeah just
like hey man we got a win and we're
going home yep I remember
um we were sitting at the locker one
game and you asked me like moo is this
what playoffs feels like it hit me and I
was like Wow Mike Trout who is 10 time
All-Star nine times Silver Slugger
three-time MVP all these things hasn't
really experienced playoffs to get that
taste pre-season yeah I mean it was
something different you know the fans
the championship game was the media
coverage was I mean I've never seen so
many media something was different you
want to be in big games like that yeah
that's why we play that's why we play